PROFESSOR: There is one handout
being passed out, it's
chapters four and five, so
be sure to pick it up.
And just a reminder that there
is a homework due on next
Wednesday, so we have homeworks
due every week in
this course as well.
So last class, we covered
Chapters One through Three
quite quickly rather, because
it was mostly a review of
6.450, and one of the key ideas
we covered last class
was the connection between
continuous time and discrete
time systems.
So we have continuous
time, discrete time.
A specific example that
we saw was that of an
orthonormal PAM system.
The architecture for a PAM
system is as follows: you have
Xk, a sequence of symbols
coming in, they
get into a PAM modulator.
What you get out is a wave form,
X of t, is what the PAM
modulator produces.
You have a little noise on the
channel, and what you receive
out is Y of t.
So Y of t is the wave form that
the receiver receives,
and what a canonical receiver's
structure to a
matched filter followed
by sampling.
So what you get out is a
sequence of symbols Y of t.
So this is a structure for an
orthonormal PAM modulator, and
the continuous time version of
the channel is that you have y
of p, which is received at
the receiver, plus X of
t, plus N of t.
The discrete time model is you
have the symbol Y of k as the
output of the sampler.
It equals X of k plus N of k.
Now basically, we say that the
two systems are equivalent in
the following sense: if you want
to make a detection of X
of k here, at the receiver,
Y of k is a sufficient
statistic, given that Y of t is
received at the front end
of the receiver.
So that's the equivalence
between discrete time and
continuous time.
And the way we established this
fact was by using the
theorem of irrelevance.
The noise here is white Gaussian
noise, so if we
project it onto orthonormal wave
forms, the corresponding
noise samples would be IID.
The noise will be independent of
everything which is out of
band, and so there is no
correlation among the noise
samples, and Y of k is a
sufficient statistic
to detect X of k.
So that is the basic idea.
Now, a similar architecture
also holds when your
continuous time system operates
in fast band rather
than base band, except the main
difference now is instead
of a PAM modulation, you have
a QAM modulator, and your
symbols, X of k and N of k, will
be complex numbers rather
than the real numbers.
Now the connection between
continuous time and discrete
time systems can be made more
precise by relating some
parameters in continuous time
with those in discrete time.
OK?
So we have continuous time
parameters, and discrete time
parameters.
So a continuous time parameter
is a bandwidth, W. A discrete
time parameter is given by
symbol interval T, and the
relation is T equals
1 over 2W.
This is for a PAM system.
OK?
So something is shown in 6.450,
and it's shown by using
Nyquist's ISI criteria.
Do not want to have ISI in the
system, the maximum symbol
rate, or rather the minimum
symbol rate,
would be 1 over 2W.
You cannot send symbols
faster than this rate.
A second criteria is power,
which is P here,
in continuous time.
In discrete time the equivalent
parameter is energy
per two dimensions.
It's denoted by Es, and Es is
related to P by using Es
equals 2 times PT.
Note that this is for two
dimensions, meaning in PAM we
have one symbol per dimension,
so this is for two symbols.
This is energy for two symbols
for a PAM modulator, and the
relation is Es equals
2 times PT.
T is the time for
the one symbol.
We also -- we are looking at
energy for two symbols, so we
multiply P by 2T.
OK?
Noise in continuous time is
AWGN, for Additive White
Gaussian Noise process, and the
power spectral density is
flat on positive support
of bandwidth, and
the height is N_0.
OK, so this is how the
spectral density is.
In 6.450, we looked at
double-sided power spectral
density when the height was N_0
over two, but it was going
over both the positive and
negative part of the bandwidth.
Here, we are only looking at
the positive part of the
bandwidth, and we are going
to scale noise by N_0.
This is just a convention.
In discrete time, your noise
sequence is Nk, and is an IID
and you take them as Gaussians
with zero mean, and variance
of N_0 over 2.
So we have noise which
has a variance of
N_0 over 2 per dimension.
And this was, again, shown by
this theorem that when you
project noise onto each of the
orthonormal wave forms, you
get the variance
is N_0 over 2.
OK?
Instead of a base band system,
if you had a fast band system,
then instead of having
a PAM modulator, we
would have a QAM modulator.
So if instead of PAM we had a
QAM then the main difference
now would be that these symbols
are going to be
complex numbers instead
of real.
So what's the symbol interval
now going to be?
AUDIENCE: 1 over W.
PROFESSOR: It's going
to be 1 over W.
Instead of sending a real
symbol, we are sending one
complex symbol, which is
occupying two dimensions, and
our symbol rate is going to be 1
over W. Well, the energy for
two dimensions, is still given
by Es equals 2PT, or
equivalently, P over W. OK?
Or that's --
The noise samples Nk are still
IID, but now they are complex
Gaussians, with zero mean,
and variance N_0.
Or equivalently, they
have a variance of
N_0 over 2 per dimension.
So what we see here is that we
can have analogous definitions
for discrete time and continuous
time, and one of
the key parameters that comes up
over and over again in the
analysis is this notion of
signal to noise ratio.
The signal to noise ratio is
defined as the energy per two
dimensions, over the noise
variance per two dimensions.
So that's the definition of
signal to noise ratio.
Es, well, it's 2PT, or
equivalently, P over W. The
noise variance for two
dimensions is N_0, so the
definition is the same as --
SNR equals P over N_0 W. OK,
are there any questions?
The other notion we talked about
last time is this idea
of the spectral efficiency.
In continuous time, the
definition is quite natural.
It's denoted by symbol rho.
The units are bits per second
per Hertz, and it's basically
R over W. You have R bits
per second over W hertz.
So it's the amount of
information bits that I'm able
to send over the amount
of bandwidth that
I have in my system.
In discrete time, we can also
define the same idea of
spectral efficiency, but it's
usually -- and a good way to
think about spectral efficiency
from a point of
view of a design
of an encoder.
What the encoder does, is you
have an encoder here, it takes
a sequence of bits in--
so say you have b
bits coming in--
and it produces N symbols.
So this could be X1, X2,
Xn, and you have a
sequence of B bits --
b1, b2, b subcapital B. This
is how an encoder operates.
It maps a sequence of bits
to a sequence of symbols.
Now where does the encoder fit
into this architecture?
It fits right here at
the front, right?
You have bits coming in, you
encode them, you produce a
sequence of symbols, and you
send them over the channel.
So if I have this encoder,
what's my the spectral
efficiency going to be?
Well, you have to ask what
the encoder does, right?
So from here, we have
a PAM modulator.
So it's basically this
from here on, we
are back to the system.
So what's the spectral
efficiency
now for this system?
How many bits do you
have per symbol?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You have B over
N bits per symbol.
Now how many symbols do you have
per dimension, if this is
an orthonormal PAM system?
AUDIENCE: One symbol
per dimension.
PROFESSOR: You have one symbol
per dimension, right?
So you have B bits per N
dimensions, in other words.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So in QAM how many
-- you have usually how many
symbols per dimension?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Half symbols
per dimension, right.
So in that case, the spectral
efficiency --
the units are bits per two
dimensions, is 2B over N. B
over N bits per dimension,
because the units are bits per
two dimensions, you get
2B over N bits per two
dimensions.
OK?
Now a natural question to ask
is, how is this definition
related to this definition
here?
This is quite the natural
definition, and here we have
imposed this encoder
structure.
Are the two definitions
equivalent in any way?
And in order to understand
this, let us take
a one-second snapshot.
So now in one second, I can
send N equals 2W symbols.
Because this is an orthonormal
PAM system, I can send 2W
symbols per second, but
in one second, I can
send N equals 2W symbols.
Because my rate is R bits per
second, B equals R, in one
second I can send R bits.
So now my definition of rho,
which I defined to be 2B over
N, is same as 2R over 2W, which
is R over W. So the
definitions in continuous time
and discrete time are
equivalent.
OK?
Now, why is spectral efficiency
very important?
Well, there is a very famous
theorem by Shannon which gives
us a nice upper bound on the
spectral efficiency.
Perhaps the most important
theorem in communications is
Shannon's Theorem, it says
that if you have an AWGN
system with a certain SNR, then
you can immediately bound
the spectral efficiency by log2
of 1 plus SNR bits per
two dimensions.
This is a very powerful
statement.
Equivalently, the capacity of an
AWGN channel is log2 1 plus
SNR bits per second.
So one important observation
here is if I have a
communication system, and if
what I care about is the
spectral efficiency of the
capacity, there are only two
terms that are important.
One is the signal to noise
ratio, which is P over N_0 W,
which is defined here.
So the individual units of P and
N_0 doesn't matter, it's
only the ratio of P over
N_0 that matters.
And the second parameter is the
bandwidth W that we have
in the system.
So signal to noise ratio and
bandwidth are in some sense
fundamental to the system.
An operational meaning of this
theorem is that if I look at
this encoder, then it gives me
an upper bound of how many
bits I can put for
each symbol.
The number of bits that I can
put on each symbol is upper
bounded by this term here,
log2 1 plus SNR.
I cannot put arbitrarily many
bits per each symbol here.
Now in order to make such a
statement, there has to be
some criteria that we
need to satisfy.
And what is the criteria
for Shannon's Theorem?
In order to make such a
statement, I need to say that
some objective function
has to be satisfied.
Because in some sense, I could
just put any number of bits I
could have on upper
symbol, right?
The encoder could just
put 100 or 200 bits.
What's going to limit me?
AUDIENCE: Probability
of error?
PROFESSOR: The probability
of error.
So this assumes that --
OK?
Now, you're not responsible for
the proof of this theorem,
it is in Chapter Three
of the notes.
Basically, it's just a random
coding argument, which is
quite standard in information
theory.
So if you already taken
information theory or
otherwise, you would probably
have seen that argument
involves bounding atypical
events that happen.
So the probability of error is
an atypical event, and we use
asymptotic equipartition
property to
bound the error event.
There's a standard proof in
Cover and Thomas, for example.
Now the main difference in
Professor Forney's approach is
that he uses this Theory
of Large Deviations.
Theory of Large Deviations
basically gives you a bound on
the occurrence of rare events,
and it is well-known in
statistical mechanics.
So it's kind of a different
approach to the same problem.
The basic idea is same as you
would find in a standard
proof, but it uses --
it comes from this idea of
large deviations theory.
So for those of you who are
taking information theory or
already have seen it, I urge
you, go at some point, take a
look at this proof.
It's quite cool.
I already saw somebody reading
this last Friday, and it was
quite impressive.
So I urge more of
you to do that.
So now that we have the spectral
efficiency, a natural
thing is to plot how
the spectral
efficiency looks like.
So what I'm going to plot is
as a function of SNR the
spectral efficiency.
Typically, when you plot SNR
on the x-axis, you almost
always plot it on a dB scale.
But I'm going to make one
exception this time, and I'm
going to plot this on
a linear scale.
So this point is zero, or minus
infinity dB here, and
I'm going to plot --
well I should call this,
actually, rho Shannon, so I
don't confuse the notation.
So we'll define rho Shannon
as log2 1 plus SNR.
So this is rho Shannon here,
and we want to plot rho
Shannon as a function of SNR.
Now if my SNR is really small,
log 1 plus SNR is
approximately linear, so I get
a linear increase here.
If my SNR is large, then the
logarithmic behavior kicks
into this expression here, so
now the spectral efficiency
grows slower and slower
with SNR.
So this is a basic shape for
my spectral efficiency.
And this immediately suggests
that there are two different
operating regimes we have.
One regime where the spectral
efficiency increases linearly
with SNR, another regime where
the spectral efficiency
increases logarithmically
with SNR.
So if SNR is very small, then
we call this regime as
power-limited regime.
And if SNR is large,
we call this the
bandwidth-limited regime.
These are our definitions.
And let's see what motivates
their names.
Suppose I have a 3 dB increase
in my SNR, and I am in power
limited regime.
How does rho Shannon increase?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: A factor
of 2, right?
Basically, if I have a 3 dB
increase in SNR, my SNR
increases by a factor of 2.
In this regime, rho Shannon
increases linearly with SNR,
so I have a factor of 2 increase
in my spectral
efficiency.
What about this regime here?
If SNR increases by 3 dB, how
does rho Shannon increase?
It increases by one bit
per two dimensions.
Units of rho are bits
I have a logarithmic behavior
kicking in, so rho is
approximately log SNR.
If I increase SNR by a factor
of 2, I get an additional 1
bit per two dimension scale.
OK?
If I increase my bandwidth in
the power-limited regime by a
factor of 2.
So this bandwidth here increases
by a factor of 2,
how does my capacity change,
if I'm in the
power-limited regime?
There's no change, right?
Or is there a change?
I'm in the power-limited regime
here, and I increase my
bandwidth by a factor of 2.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
What is my SNR?
It's P over W N_0.
So what happens if
I fix P over N_0?
OK, yeah, so you had it.
Basically, if I double my
bandwidth, my SNR decreases by
a factor of 2, so this term
here is like SNR over 2, W
increases by a factor
of 2, and there is
no change in bandwidth.
So let's do it more slowly.
So we have, say, in the --
and say, my C is now
W log2 1 plus SNR.
Instead of SNR, I will write
P over N_0 W. So this
approximately is W times
P over N_0 W times log
E to the base 2.
And this is approximately --
this is basically P over N_0
times log E to the base 2.
So in other words, in the
power-limited regime, changing
bandwidth has no effect
on the capacity.
What happens in the
bandwidth-limited regime?
Well, in this case
C equals W log2.
Well, I can say approximately,
and I can ignore this factor
of 1, because P over N_0 W is
large, because my SNR is large
in the bandwidth-limited
regime.
I'm operating in this
part of the graph.
So this is P over N_0 W. Now
suppose I increase my
bandwidth by a factor of 2.
C prime will be 2W log2
over P over 2 W N_0.
All right?
This, I can write it as 2W log2
P over N_0 W minus --
this is to the base 2, so
I can write a 1 here.
And this term is approximately
same --
if I ignore the 1, if I assume
P over N_0 W is quite large,
then I can just ignore
the subtraction of 1.
So I get 2W log2 P over N_0 W,
or it's equivalently 2C.
OK, so in other words, in the
bandwidth-limited regime, if I
increase my W by a factor of 2,
the capacity approximately
increases by a factor of 2.
So that's what motivates
the name
bandwidth-limited regime here.
Are there any questions?
OK.
All right.
So it turns out that there are
two points I wanted to say.
First of all, one might ask,
that fine, these seem to be
interesting definitions, that
SNR is much smaller than one,
and SNR is much larger than one,
but is there any kind of
hard division between the
bandwidth-limited regime and
power-limited regime?
I mean, the general
answer is no.
It's basically --
because there is some point when
the capacity appears not
strictly logarithmically,
or strictly
linearly in terms of SNR.
But from an engineering point
of view, we take rho equals
two bits per two dimension as
a dividing point between the
two regimes.
And one motivation to see why
rho equals two bits per two
dimension is a good choice is
because this is the maximum
spectral efficiency we can get
from binary modulation.
OK, if you want to have spectral
efficiency more than
two bits per two dimensions, you
have to go to multi-level
modulation, and that's one of
the reasons why this choice is
often used in practice.
Another point is that the
bandwidth-limited regime and
power-limited regime, they
behave quite differently in
almost all criterias that
you can think about.
So usually, with
the analysis --
we keep them separately and do
the analysis differently in
the bandwidth and power-limited
regime, and
that's what we will be doing in
the subsequent part of this
lecture and next lecture.
So we start with the
power-limited regime.
Now, we already saw that in
doubling the power doubles rho
S, and doubling bandwidth
does not change C.
OK, the other point I
mentioned was binary
modulation is sufficient in
this regime, because our
spectral efficiency is less
than two bits per two
dimensions, so the idea is to
have a strong code followed by
binary modulation.
What else?
Right.
Typically, the normalization
is done in
per information bit.
What does this mean?
When we are wanting to compare
different systems, we will
look at all the parameters
normalized
per information bit.
For example, if we want to look
at the probability of
error, we look at this quantity
here, Pb of E, which
is the probability of error
per information bit, as a
function of Eb/N_0.
This is an important trade-off
that we wish to study in
power-limited regime.
Eb is the energy per bit, P sub
b of E is the probability
of error per information bit.
So I want to spend some time on
this Eb/N_0, because it's
an important concept
that we'll be using
often in the course.
So what is Eb/N_0?
It's sometimes also known as Eb
over N_0, so it depends how
you wish to call it.
What is energy per bit
in terms of Es?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, Es
over rho, right?
Energy per bit.
Well, Es is energy per
two dimensions.
Rho is bits per two dimensions,
so Eb is Es over
rho, and you have N_0 here.
And Es over N_0 is also our SNR,
so this is SNR over rho.
OK, so that's how Eb/N_0
is defined.
Now we know from Shannon that
rho is always less than log2 1
plus SNR, or equivalently,
2 to the rho minus 1
is less than SNR.
If I sub in here, this means
that SNR is greater than 2 to
the rho minus 1 over
rho, and then we're
just dividing by rho.
So Eb/N_0 is always greater
than 2 to the rho
minus 1 over rho.
And this is quite an interesting
observation.
For example, if you are
analyzing the feasibility of a
communication system, which
has a certain spectral
efficiency, and a certain
Eb/N_0, then you can
immediately check this relation,
to see if it is a
system in the first place.
What Shannon says is that Eb/N_0
is always going to be
greater than 2 to the rho
minus 1 over rho.
So if you see that this relation
is not satisfied,
immediately know something
is wrong.
This actually reminds me of an
interesting anecdote that
Professor Forney once
mentioned when I
was taking the class.
Well he has been in this field
since the '60's, and so he has
seen a lot of this stuff.
He was saying when
turbo codes --
which is one of the first
capacity approaching codes in
recent years when they
were proposed --
they presented the results
at ICC, the International
Conference in Communications,
and what they saw was that the
performance was very close to
the limit that we can predict.
Eb/N_0 was very close to
the ultimate limit --
the Eb/N_0 achieved by turbo
codes was very close to the
ultimate limit that one can
predict, at least 3 dB better
than the best codes that
were available there.
So most people just thought that
there was something wrong
in the simulations, and they
told them that there was a
factor of 2 missing
somewhere, so they
should just double check.
But it turned out when they went
back and people actually
implemented these codes, they
were actually very close to
the capacity.
So sometimes, you have
to be careful.
If you are not going below this
limit, it could be that
the system is good.
And when it is, it's a really
important breakthrough.
Ok
So one particular concept that
comes here is the idea of
ultimate Shannon limit.
And basically, if we are talking
about power limited
regime, our SNR is very small.
So our spectral efficiency is
going to be quite small.
Now notice that this function
here it monotonically
increasing in rho.
It's easy to show that this
function here increases
monotonically in rho.
You could just differentiate
this, or there's easier ways
to do a Taylor expansion of 2 to
the rho minus 1, the series
expansion and show each
term is positive.
So if this term is always
going to be greater
than this term here.
So I'm going from
here to here.
Limit rho tends to zero of 2 to
the rho minus 1 over rho.
This is going to be -- it's a
simple calculus exercise to
show this is the natural
log of 2, or in dB,
it's minus 1.59 dB.
So no matter what system you
design, your Eb/N_0 is always
going to be greater than
minus 1.59 dB.
That's basically what this
calculation shows.
And when is it achieved?
Well, it's only achieved
when the spectral
efficiency goes to zero.
So if you have a deep space
communication system, where
you have lots and lots of
bandwidth, and you do not care
about spectral efficiency, then
if your only criteria is
to minimize Eb/N_0, then you
can design your system
accordingly, check how much
Eb/N_0 you require for a
certain probability of error,
and see how far you are from
the ultimate Shannon limit.
So in this way, in the
power-limited regime, you can
quantify your gap to capacity,
if you will, through this
ultimate Shannon limit.
OK, are there any questions?
OK.
So now let's look at the
bandwidth-limited regime.
So we already saw two
things in the
bandwidth-limited regime.
If I double P, my spectral
efficiency increases by one
bit per two dimension.
Similarly, if I double bandwidth
by C, capacity
approximately doubles.
Now, because you want a spectral
efficiency of more
than two bits per two dimension,
in this system you
typically do a multi-level
modulation.
So for those of you who are
familiar, we do things like
trellis-coded modulation, and
bit-interleaved coded
modulation, and so on.
If we have time, we'll be seeing
those things towards
the very end of the course.
This is not a subject of
the course as such.
The normalization in this
regime is done for two
dimensions.
So if you want to normalize
all the quantities, we
normalize them for two
dimensions here.
And particularly, we will be
seeing probability of error as
a function of this quantity
called SNR norm.
So this is the performance
analysis that is done in
bandwidth-limited regimes.
Here Ps of E is the probability
of error for two
dimensions.
What is SNR norm?
It's defined to be SNR over
2 to the rho minus 1.
Why do we divide by 2
to the rho minus 1?
Well, that's the minimum SNR
that you require for the best
possible system.
That's what Shannon
says, right?
So this quantity here is always
going to be greater
than 1, or 0 dB.
So OK, well, this is the
ultimate Shannon limit in the
bandwidth-limited regime.
If you have a system that is
designed, that operates at a
certain SNR and a certain
spectral efficiency, you can
calculate SNR norm and see how
far you are from 0 dB.
If you're very close to 0
dB, then that's great.
You have a very good
system in practice.
If not, then you have room
for improvement.
And so, in other
words, SNR norm
defines the gap to capacity.
OK, so let's do an example.
Suppose we have an
M-PAM system.
So we have an M-PAM
constellation.
So how does it look like?
Well, you have points here
on a linear line.
This point is say minus alpha,
alpha, three alpha minus three
alpha, all the way up to m minus
one alpha, and here,
minus of m minus one alpha.
Assume m is an even number.
So the distance between two
points here is two alpha, any
two points.
Now we want to find the SNR norm
given that we are using
this constellation.
So in other words, if I use
this constellation in my
communication system, how far
am I operating from the
ultimate Shannon limit?
OK, that's the question.
So in order to find what we need
to find, is first energy
for two dimensions.
Does anybody remember the
formula for M-PAM?
Well, there was a very nice
way of doing it in 450.
One natural way is to simply sum
up all of the coordinates
here, square them, and divide by
M. And because it's for two
dimensions, we could do it --
we're to multiply by a factor
of two, because it's for two
dimensions--
and summation of Xk squared.
And if you work out, you will
get some answer here.
Another way that was
shown in 450 --
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: With uniform
quantization, exactly.
So the idea here is, you have
a source, say, which is
uniformly distributed between
M alpha and minus M alpha.
So you have a source uniformly
distributed, and it can be
easily seen by inspection that
M-PAM is the best quantizer
for this particular source.
Ok.
So the interval regions are
just of equal width.
Each interval region is width
two alpha, so your mean square
error, if you will, is 2 alpha
squared over 12, so it's alpha
squared over 3.
Well, the variance in your
source, which I will denote by
sigma square s, is 2M alpha
squared over 12, or it's M
squared alpha squared over 3.
So your energy per symbol --
it's energy in your quantizer,
so I'm denoting it by E of A
in order to differentiate it by
Es, because Es is two times
E of A, OK?
It's going to be m squared
minus 1 times alpha
squared over 3.
So Es is 2 E of A, and so we
get it's 2 times alpha
squared, m squared
minus 1 over 3.
OK, so can anybody tell me what
the spectral efficiency
will be for the system, if I
use an M-PAM constellation?
Well, how many bits per
symbol do I have?
AUDIENCE: Log2M.
PROFESSOR: Log2 M
bits per symbol.
So since it's bits per two
dimensions, the sum would be 2
logM to the base 2.
Ok?
So right now, we have pretty
much everything we need to
find SNR norm.
The SNR here is Es over N_0,
so it's 2 alpha squared, M
squared minus 1, over 3N_0.
But remember, N_0 by definition
is 2 sigma squared,
because sigma squared
is N_0 over 2.
That's how -- that's the noise
variance per dimension.
So, I had 3 times 2 times sigma
squared, or I will just
write this as 6 times sigma
squared, and that's going to
be -- this is just
multiplication, so I should
not even write it --
six sigma squared.
So this is alpha squared,
M squared minus 1
over 3 sigma squared.
OK, so now SNR norm is SNR over
2 to the rho minus 1.
2 to the rho minus 1 is just
M squared minus 1.
It cancels with this M squared
minus 1, and so I get alpha
squared over 3 sigma squared.
So that's the SNR norm if
I use an M-PAM system.
AUDIENCE: Why is [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, N_0 --
I've plugged in for SNR 3 here,
so I have 3 N_0, but N_0
is 2 sigma squared.
Did I miss anything?
Ok?
Any questions?
OK, so there are two important
remarks from this example.
The first remark is that SNR
norm is independent of M. So I
started with an M-PAM
constellation, so it's a
different constellation for
each value of M, right?
If I look at my spectral
efficiency rho, it's different
for each value of M, because I
can pack more and more bits
per symbol as I increase M. If
I look at my signal to noise
ratio, it's also a function of
M. But when I took SNR norm,
remarkably, the M squared minus
1 term cancelled out in
the numerator and denominator,
and what I was left with was
something independent of M.
So this is actually quite
an interesting result.
What it says is suppose I design
a system, an M-PAM
system, that has this
particular spectral
efficiency, then my gap to
capacity is given by this
expression.
If I use a different value of
M, my gap to the ultimate
Shannon limit is still given
by this expression here.
So by increasing value of M or
decreasing the value of M, my
gap to the Shannon limit is
still going to be the same.
For each value of M, I will
have a different spectral
efficiency, but I'm not getting
any kind of coding
gain, if you will, here.
OK, so this motivates that M-PAM
is an uncoded system.
All of them have the same gap
to the Shannon limit,
regardless of what the value
of M is, and so.
The second point to note is if
I look at the value of alpha
squared over 3 sigma square,
I can make it
quite small, right?
I can even, if I decrease
alpha really by a great
amount, I can make this quantity
smaller than 1.
OK?
I told you here that SNR norm
is always greater than 1.
So what happened?
Did I lie to you here, or did
I do something wrong here?
I mean, I can choose any alpha,
right, and make this
quantity as small as I please,
and then I'm doing better than
the Shannon limit.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So basically, what's missing
in this calculation is
probability of error.
If I make alpha really small,
what I have is all these
points come closer and closer,
and sure, I seem like I'm
doing very well at
the encoder.
But what happens
at the decoder?
There is noise in the system,
and so I get too many errors.
This lower bound clearly assumes
that you can make your
probability of error
quite small,
arbitrarily small, right?
So in any reasonable system,
I should also look at the
probability of error.
If I make alpha really small,
I'm going to have too much
error at the decoder, and so
I won't be able to have a
practical system.
So the comment is SNR norm
cannot be seen in isolation.
We need to couple SNR norm
with the corresponding
probability of error.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What I mean
by uncoded syst --
that's a good question.
What do I mean by
uncoded system?
All I'm really saying here is
M-PAM system is a fairly
simple system to implement,
right?
Irregardless of what value of M
I get, I have a certain gap
to the Shannon limit, which is
independent of M. So if I
start with a simple system,
where I have bits coming in,
each bit gets mapped to one
symbol, and I send it over the
channel, I have a fixed gap
to the Shannon capacity.
And this, I will call
an uncoded system.
My only hope will be to improve
upon this system.
OK?
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So, if I'm multiplying
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, right.
I'm assuming the fixed alpha.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I mean, basically,
you will see that alpha is a
function of Es, right?
And I want to --
so why do I want -- the question
is, why do I want to
keep alpha fixed, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK, so in order to
understand that, I have to
look at energy for
two dimensions.
If I normalize by M squared
minus one --
that doesn't work out.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
so the constellation cannot be
expanding [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, so I wanted
to always plot by keeping
alpha fixed.
And I mean, the point is,
typically you want to plot the
probability of symbol error --
do I have that expression
anywhere?
Right there.
Ps of p is a function
of SNR norm, right?
And that will be -- if I
increase SNR norm, so it will
be some kind of a
graph, right?
A trade-off.
Basically, alpha will define the
trade-off between SNR norm
and Ps of p.
So as I slip over larger and
larger values of alpha, for
different values of M, then I
will have a trade-off as Ps of
p is a function of SNR norm.
Does that make sense?
So say I fixed a
value of M, OK?
I define SNR norm, which
is alpha squared
over 3 sigma squared.
For this, I will get a certain
probability of error now.
So if I fix this value of SNR
norm, I get a certain
probability of error.
What if I want to increase
my SNR norm?
The only way to do that will
be to increase alpha.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
You're defining SNR norm as the
gap to capacity, but it
seems like, I mean, obviously as
you increase alpha, as you
increase your signal energy,
you're going to do better and
better, right?
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Well, in
terms of what?
In terms of probability of
error, like achievable
probability of error, or?
PROFESSOR: Right, exactly.
So basically, the point is say
I plot Ps of E as a function
of SNR norm, or as a function
of alpha squared
over 3 sigma squared.
So my core will look
like this.
AUDIENCE: But the gap to
capacity is defined all the
way over here on the left,
is that what--?
PROFESSOR: Right, that's
a very good question.
You are going much ahead
then what I thought.
So basically, at zero, seven,
SNR norm is zero, right?
This is in linear scale,
so when I have
one, SNR norm is one.
I have the Shannon system.
Basically, for any SNR norm
greater than 1, what Shannon
says is your probability of
error will be arbitrarily
small, and here, it
will be large.
So this here is the
Shannon limit.
And now, in a practical system,
what I want to do is I
want to fix the probability
of error.
So say I like probability
of error of ten
to the minus five.
So that's something that
the system specifies.
And from that, I know the
gap to the capacity.
So if here, if I require, this
is my SNR norm, then this is
going to be my gap.
I wanted to cover
it, but later.
That's a good point.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, this is a
certain, specific system, the
M-PAM system.
What Shannon says that, if
you're anywhere here, you
should be able to make your
probability of error
arbitrarily small.
So your code should basically
look something like this, if
you will, or even steeper.
AUDIENCE: What's the difference
between that curve
and the wider curve?
PROFESSOR: This curve
and this curve?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: This is
basically what we
achieved by an M-PAM system.
I don't want to go into too much
of this, because we'll be
doing this later.
This is the next topic.
Ideally, what we would want is
something, basically, this is
my Shannon limit, I want
something such as the
probability of error decreases
right away as soon as I am
just away from the
Shannon limit.
All right.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's a good point.
So if I did not do coding,
this is what I get.
If I did coding, this
is what I would get.
So this is how much I can expect
a gain from coding.
AUDIENCE: So in other words,
basically, this bound is
basically in my channel,
the SNR is such that --
I mean, I'm so energy limited
that my SNR norm is lower than
a certain amount, there's
nothing I can do, basically,
is what it's saying.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Because if you want a certain
spectral efficiency, there's
also spectral efficiency,
right?
And if your SNR is much lower,
you're out of luck.
AUDIENCE: So basically, you
have to make your spectral
efficiency higher --
or, lower.
PROFESSOR: Lower, right.
Exactly.
So now let us start with the
probability of error analysis,
and we'll start in
limited regime.
So we have Eb of E as a function
of Eb/N_0, we want to
quantify this trade-off.
Basically, what we are doing now
is trying to quantify how
this graph will look like,
at least for the
uncoded systems today.
We'll do coding next class,
or two classes from
now, as we get time.
So say I have a constellation,
A, as binary PAM.
So it takes only two values,
minus alpha and alpha.
So I have these two points here,
alpha and minus alpha.
My receiveds are Y, symbol Y is
X plus n, where X belongs
to A, and N is Gaussian zero
mean, variance sigma squared,
where sigma squared
is N_0 over 2.
And now what want to do at the
receiver is given Y, you want
to decide whether X was
alpha or minus alpha.
That's a standard detection
problem.
So how will the probability
of error look like?
So suppose I transmit X equals
alpha, my conditional
density of Y --
let me make some room here --
will be a bell shaped curve,
because of the Gaussian noise.
So this is P of Y given
X equals alpha.
Similarly, if I have set X
equals minus alpha, what I get
is something like this.
This is p of Y given X
equals minus alpha.
Excuse my handwriting there.
And the decision region is at
the midpoint, Y equals zero.
This is a standard binary
detection problem.
If Y is positive, you will say
X equals alpha was sent.
If Y is negative, you will say X
equals minus alpha was sent.
And your probability of error
is simply the probability of
error under this --
graph under these
two curves here.
So we want to find what the
probability of error is.
Just let me just do quickly the
calculation, in order to
remind you.
We'll be doing this over
and over again.
We'll just do it once.
Without loss in generality, I
can say this is probability of
error, given X equals minus
alpha, where both the points
are equally likely.
So by symmetry, I
can say that.
So this is the same as
probability that Y is greater
than zero, given X
is minus alpha.
Now Y is X plus N, so this is
same as probability that N --
yeah capital N --
is greater than alpha.
Since N has zero mean variance
sigma squared, this is a
standard Q function of
alpha over sigma.
OK, so that's the probability
of error.
Now, there is one bit per symbol
for each X that is one
bit, so probability of error is
also same as probability of
bit error, so this is also Pb of
E. So I have Pb of E equals
Q of alpha over sigma, and
now, I want to basically
express it as a function
of Eb/N_0, right.
So what is Eb for the system?
It's going to be
alpha squared.
Sigma squared is now N_0 over 2,
so alpha squared over sigma
squared is 2 Eb over N_0.
So now my probability of bit
error is this Q function of
root 2 Eb over N_0.
OK?
So let us plot this.
So I'm on the x-axis,
I'm plotting Eb/N_0,
which is in dB scale.
On the y-axis, I'm
going to plot the
probability of bit error.
Typically, what you do is
you plot the y-axis
on a semi-log scale.
So this is ten to the minus six,
ten to the minus five.
If you want to do this in
MATLAB, you can use this
command semi-log y,
and that does it.
And so on.
So can anybody say what will
be a good candidate for the
x-value at this point here?
So what should be the Eb/N_0
at this point?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It should be the
Shannon limit, right?
You cannot hope to go below
the Shannon limit.
So now, what Shannon
says is that --
so I'm going to plot this as
my Shannon limit here.
This probability of error will
basically use the standard
waterfall curve.
This is 2-PAM.
And if you look at the
x-coordinates, then the value
at ten to the minus
five is 9.6 dB.
So as a system designer, if you
care about probability of
error at ten to the negative
five, then your gap to
capacity, or gap to the ultimate
limit, if you will,
will be this, 9.6 minus
of minus 1.59 dB.
OK, I should not erase this.
OK, so the first thing is at N
to the minus five, our gap to
the ultimate limit is 9.6
plus 1.59 dB, and that's
approximately 11.2 dB.
OK?
But there is one
catch to this.
This particular system has a
spectral efficiency of two
bits for two dimensions, whereas
if you want to achieve
something close to the Shanon
limit, you have to drive the
spectral efficiency
down to zero.
So you might say that this
is not a fair comparison.
So if you do want to make a fair
comparison, you want to
fix rho to be two bits
for two dimensions.
So if you fix rho for two bits
per two dimensions, you will
get a limit somewhere,
not at 1.59 dB, but
at some other point.
This is if you fix rho2, two
bits for two dimensions.
Can anybody say what
that point will be?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 3 over 2.
1.5.
What will it be in
the log scale?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 1.76.
Good.
So what we do know --
if we do the calculation here.
If you fix rho2, two bits for
two dimensions, your Eb/N_0,
we know, is greater than 2 to
the rho minus 1 over rho,
which is 3 over 2.
And that is, if you remember
your dB tables, 1.76 dB.
Log of 3 is like 4.7, log of 2
is like 3, so it's 1.76 dB.
So in this case, your gap to the
ultimate limit is going to
be 9.6 minus 1.76, which
comes out to be 7.8 dB.
OK?
So now, let us do the
bandwidth-limited regime.
Now in bandwidth-limited regime,
the trade-off is Ps of
E as a function of SNR norm.
OK, so that's the trade-off
we seek for.
And the baseline system
we will be
using is an M-PAM system.
So now, your constellation is
going to be minus alpha,
alpha, 3 alpha, minus 3 alpha,
and so on, up to M
minus 1 alpha --
I always run out
of room here --
minus M minus 1 alpha.
This is your constellation.
Now what's the probability of
error going to be for this
constellation?
Well, what's the probability
of error for each
intermediate point?
There are two ways you
can make an error.
Say we say alpha, your noise
is either too small, so it
takes you to minus alpha.
Your noise is too high, so
it takes you to 3 alpha.
For each one, the probability
will be Q of --
this distance is 2 alpha, it
would be Q of alpha over
sigma, because you will be
having your decision regions
right here.
So in other words, for each
intermediate point -- and
there are M minus
two of this --
your probability of error would
be 2 times Q of alpha
over sigma.
OK?
And how many of them
there are?
There are M minus 2 of these.
And if all the points are
equally likely, and you want
to find the probability of
error, you divide by M.
For the two end points, the
noise can only make an error
in one direction.
So you get two over M times
Q of alpha over sigma.
You work this out, and you have
two times M minus 1 over
M, times Q of alpha
over sigma.
Now, we want to find probability
of error for two
symbols, because that's
what Ps of E is, OK?
So what's Ps of E going to be?
Well, it's -- in terms of Pr
of E, it's going to be one
minus one minus Pr
of E squared.
This is the probability you make
error in none of the two
symbols, and 1 minus that will
be the probability of error
you make in at least
one symbol.
And that's going to be equal to
two Pr of E, or it's four
times M minus 1 over M,
Q of alpha over sigma.
Good, I did not write
on this board.
So now what remains to do
is to relate alpha over
sigma to SNR norm.
And I had it on this
board here.
SNR norm, we just did in the
previous example, for an M-PAM
system is alpha squared
over 3 sigma squared.
OK?
So I plug that in here, so I get
Ps of E is 4 times M minus
1 over M times Q of
root 3 SNR norm.
And if M is large, this is
approximately 4 times Q of
root 3 SNR norm.
So we are plotting now
probability of error as a
function of SNR norm, similar to
what we did in that part in
the power-limited
regime there.
So this is Ps of E as a
function of SNR norm.
Now my Shannon limit would be at
0 dB, so this is my Shannon
limit point.
This is ten to the minus six,
ten to the minus five, ten to
the minus four, ten to the minus
three, ten to the minus
two, and so on.
This is going to be the
performance of M-PAM.
And again, I turn to the minus
five, which will be the kind
of performance criteria
we'll be using
throughout this course.
You'll see that this
y-axis is 8.4 dB.
So in this case, the
gap to capacity is
going to be 8.4 dB.
So if I want a certain spectral
efficiency and I use
M-PAM, I'm 8.4 dB away from
the Shannon limit.
The idea behind coding, as
someone pointed out, was to
start from here and do coding
to come closer and closer to
bridge this gap.
OK?
So are there any questions?
We are almost end time.
OK.
I think -- yes?
AUDIENCE: A perfect code would
just be literally like a step
function --
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: -- all the way down.
PROFESSOR: That's what
Shannon coded.
OK, I think this is a natural
point to stop.
We'll continue next class.